aquí tenemos una tabla de los
potenciales de reducción estándar y esta
es una versión recortada pero puedes ver
digamos del lado izquierdo de esta tabla
que tenemos semi reacciones tenemos semi
reacciones y todas estas semi reacciones
están escritas como semi reacciones de
reducción y recordemos que la reducción
significa ganancia de electrones así que
si nos fijamos en la primera reacción
digamos en esta que tenemos aquí tenemos
un guión de plata tenemos ión de plata
que está ganando un electrón para formar
plata sólida cierto así que esta es una
reacción o una semi reacción de
reducción el potencial de reducción
estándar resulta ser de 0.80 volts y
esto es positivo si eso lo comparamos lo
comparamos con esta semi reacción que
tenemos aquí abajo que de hecho voy a
subrayar toda esta reacción toda esta
semi reacción que tenemos aquí esto
corresponde
el electrodo de hidrógeno estándar
verdad que es como nuestro valor de
referencia y ese tiene un potencial de 0
volts en realidad todas nuestras otras
semi reacciones están siendo comparadas
con esta red con esta semi reacción o
que mientras más positivo sea el valor
del potencial de reducción estándar
significa que será más probable que la
sustancia sea reducida así que vamos a
comparar la reducción de uno de los
iones de cobre dos positivos ok vamos a
fijarnos en este de aquí en este de aquí
vamos a fijarnos y vamos a compararlo
con los iones de 5-2 positivos que
tenemos en esta otra semi reacción así
que si si estamos reduciendo el cobre 2
positivo en cobre sólido el potencial de
reducción estándar es de 0.34 volts
positivos verdad y si estamos reduciendo
el 5-2 positivo en zinc sólido aquí
tenemos 2 positivos al zinc
2 hay perdón a zinc sólido entonces el
valor del potencial de reducción
estándar resulta ser de menos 0.76 volts
así que mientras más positivo sea el
valor es más probable que la sustancia
sea reducida así que obviamente más 30 +
0.34 es más mucho más positivo que menos
0.6 cierto así que sabemos que ésta
tiene que ser la semi reacción la semi
reacción de reducción justo esta que
tenemos aquí y si estamos hablando de
una reacción de tipo redox estamos por
ejemplo involucre cobre y zinc entonces
esta sería nuestra semi reacción de tipo
reducción aunque así que vamos a
continuar y vamos a escribir esto esta
sería nuestra semi reacción de reducción
donde tendremos
digamos sillones de cobre dos positivos
ok en solución acuosa y este estará
ganando dos electrones para finalmente
convertirse en cobre sólido el potencial
de reducción estándar que lo denotamos
como es cero verdad de esta semi
reacción de reducción este tiene un
valor de 0.34 o solo punto 34 digamos
así que sabemos que en una reacción de
tipo redox siempre hay algo que se está
reduciendo y hay algo que se está
oxidando y dado que ya tenemos aquí
nuestra semi reacción de reducción
entonces necesitamos una semi reacción
de oxidación
eso significa que esta reacción que
habíamos considerado esta esta que
tenemos aquí
como nuestra semi reacción de oxidación
pero aquí lo tenemos escrito digamos
como si fuera una semi reacción de
reducción así que tenemos que revertir
esta reacción para fijarnos en ella como
si fuera de oxidación así que tenemos
que empezar con el zinc sólido ok
sería nuestra red semi reacción de
oxidación y empezamos con el zinc en su
forma sólida verdad y esto nos va a dar
es decir el zinc se va a oxidar en
guiones de zinc dos positivos muy bien
en solución acuosa y va a perder dos
electrones y recordemos que justamente
esa es la definición de la oxidación
verdad pérdida de electrones ahora esta
es una semi reacción de oxidación y
tenemos que encontrar el potencial de
oxidación estándar para esta semi
reacción y podemos simplemente y hacerlo
fijándonos en la tabla que tenemos aquí
arriba y simplemente nos fijamos en el
valor que tiene verdad en este caso
sería menos 0.76 que su potencial de
reducción estándar pero como hemos
revertido nuestra semi reacción
simplemente necesitamos cambiar el signo
así que el potencial de oxidación sería
el potencial de oxidación sería más 0.76
lo único que tuvimos que hacer fue
revertir el signo así que para encontrar
digamos la reacción de tipo redox
digamos completa o total tenemos que
agregar ambas semi reacciones verdad
simplemente tendremos que agregar o
sumar digamos ambas semi reacciones
vamos a encontrar la reacción digamos
completa o la reacción total y tendremos
tendremos que estos electrones se
cancelan verdad
ya que están en la dos contrarios y
simplemente del lado izquierdo nos queda
esta parte esta parte que sería guiones
de cobre dos positivos muy bien al cual
le agregamos
sólido y eso nos produce nos queda del
lado derecho justamente esto verdad
tendremos esto de aquí que sería cobre
sólido cobre sólido y iones de zinc dos
positivos en solución acuosa y esta
reacción completa digamos de tipo redox
debería ser bastante familiar para ti
porque es una reacción espontánea verdad
de la que hemos hablado en vídeos
anteriores así que que de hecho
utilizamos como ejemplo para hablar de
la celda voltaica cierto así que sabemos
que esta es una reacción espontánea
ahora como encontramos el potencial de
la celda como encontramos el potencial
de la celda el potencial digamos de la
celda simplemente sería sumar los
potenciales de las semi reacciones de
reducción y de oxidación verdad para
encontrar nuestro potencial de la celda
muy bien así que simplemente sumamos
estos esto sería el potencial
en mi reacción de reducción más el
potencial de la semi reacción de
oxidación y cuando hacemos eso vamos a
hacernos más espacio tendremos que sumar
tendremos que sumar 0.34 + 0.76 con lo
cual concluimos que el potencial de la
celda será simplemente 6 y 4 son 10 y
llevamos 13 y 7 son 10 y 17 son 11
llevamos una y tendremos que el
potencial es 1.10 positivo volts muy
bien quizás quizás debería debería poner
esto más juntos serían más 1 punto 10
volts y de hecho hablamos de que podemos
utilizar un voltímetro para medir la
diferencia de potencial verdad para
medir el voltaje de una celda voltaica y
vamos a obtener justo este valor que es
1.10 volts positivos bajo condiciones
estándar y ahora eso es algo muy bonito
que podemos hacer digamos con esta tabla
de potenciales de reducciones
podemos calcular el voltaje de nuestras
celdas voltaicas de esta forma así que
vamos a fijarnos digamos con más detalle
en nuestras semi reacciones vamos a
regresar digamos a estas que tenemos
aquí así que empecemos re analizando
esta reacción de oxidación que tenemos
por aquí esta semi reacción de oxidación
que tenemos por aquí verdad porque
sabemos que el zinc el zinc está siendo
oxidado cierto tenemos que el zinc está
perdiendo los electrones aquí tenemos
los dos electrones que está perdiendo el
zinc y esos dos electrones son los
mismos que están acá están causando la
reducción del guión de cobre verdad del
zinc que entonces es un agente para la
reducción del cobre y decimos que el
zinc es el agente de reducción vamos a
ponerlo aquí es el agente de reducción
del cobre muy bien y quizás bueno quizás
algunos alumnos pueden confundirse en
esta parte porque el zinc se está
oxidando verdad porque debería ser un
agente de
reducción bueno el zinc es el agente
para la reducción de otra cosa en este
caso sería de los iones de cobre 2
positivo así que el zinc es el agente de
reducción
por otro lado hagámoslo incluso con otro
color por otro lado tenemos el cobre 2
positivo es estrellón de cobre está
ganando estos dos electrones así que el
cobre 2 positivo se está reduciendo ok
pero debido a que el cobre 2 positivo
está ganando esos dos electrones le
permite al zinc oxidarse así que el
cobre 2 positivo a este zinc
a este zinc que tenemos acá se estaría
oxidando y entonces el cobre 2 positivo
sería un agente de oxidación para el
zinc así que en este caso sería un
agente de oxidación un agente de
oxidación por supuesto hablando de
nuestra reacción redox ahora fijémonos
en nuestra tabla de potenciales de
reducción nuevamente aquí tenemos
nuevamente nuestra tabla y veamos si
esto puede ayudarnos a entender cuándo
tendremos agentes de oxidación o agentes
de reducción y hasta ahora hemos estado
comparando estas dos reacciones esta red
está semi reacción que tenemos aquí y
esta semi reacción que tenemos por acá
así que ahora vamos a comparar vamos a
comparar los iones de cobre 2 positivo y
los iones de zinc 2 positivos sabemos
nosotros que los iones de cobre 2
positivo son más fácilmente reducido
cierto tienen y de hecho es porque
tienen un valor positivo un valor
digamos más positivo y en cuanto a su
potencial de reducción estándar verdad
los iones de cobre 2 positivos son más
fácilmente reducibles y de ahí que el
cobre 2 positivo es un agente de
oxidación más fuerte que el zinc 2
positivo así que a medida que nosotros
subimos en esta tabla a medida que
nosotros subimos en la tabla en realidad
estamos incrementando la tendencia para
que algo sea reducido y de ahí que
estemos incrementando la fuerza como
agentes de oxidación muy bien ahora
pensemos digamos de forma contraria a
medida que nosotros bajamos en el
potencial de reducción digamos en este
en este sentido sobre nuestra tabla
verdad ahora comparemos el cobre sólido
el cobre sólido con respecto al zinc
sólido verdad ahora sabemos que el zinc
sólido fue nuestro agente de reducción
en nuestra reacción y eso es porque el
potencial de reducción era más negativo
verdad
el más negativo de estos dos y era de
menos 0.76 eso significa que es más
probable que esta sea la semi reacción
de oxidación cierto así que a medida que
bajamos en nuestro potencial de
reducción tenemos una tendencia
creciente de ser oxidados verdad y de
ahí que entonces tenemos una fuerza
mayor para ser un agente de reducción
verdad entonces tenemos un incremento
digamos la tendencia de ser o la fuerza
de ser un agente de reducción así que en
resumen si nosotros bajamos digamos el
potencial de reducción en realidad
estamos incrementando la tendencia de
ser oxidado y por lo tanto incrementa la
fuerza como un agente de reducción así
que si nos fijamos en el litio que
tenemos aquí bueno este tiene un valor
mucho más negativo verdad en respecto a
su potencial de reducción de ahí que es
mucho más probable que sea una red una
semi reacción de oxidación es decir el
litio es un agente reductor más fuerte
que el zinc